books inspire us they teach us they let
us escape into new worlds
but some books do much more than this
these books hit a collective nerve
and have had a profound and lasting
effect on society
what are the titles that had this impact
there are many many books that fit this
definition
but we've managed to narrow it down to
five books that have truly
shaped our world
[Music]
melancholy can be overcome only by
melancholy
wrote robert burton in his enormous
900-page book
the anatomy of melancholy which was
first published way back in 1621.
so in the 17th century there weren't
books
about melancholy or as we would call it
today
depression it looks as if robert burton
himself
suffered from depression and there's a
real sense as he writes it that he's
writing himself into a position
of expertise about depression so he can
help himself
as well as other people and it's
remained such a kind of influential book
over the centuries since then not simply
because of its subject matter
it's the way it's written it explores
inner life
in a way that hadn't really been
explored before
so it's the patient's voice and one of
the things that we've learned over the
last 20 years is the importance of the
patient's voice
in targeting research and clinical
treatment
to 1960s america now where many people
still thought that a woman's place was
in the home
betty frieden wrote the feminine
mystique in 1963
and in the introduction describes it as
the problem that has no name
it was a book writing about the
experience and aspirations
of women in suburban america
it stood out as a book at this time
because the experience of women wasn't
being written about in this way
for the general population it stood out
because
she was standing up and saying we need
to acknowledge that there is more to
life for these women
than being the perfect wife the perfect
mother
she developed the idea that women needed
to become politicized they needed to
think about their
experience at home however and there is
a big however
the biggest criticism came from her
exclusion of
women of color poor women's experience
was excluded
she also excluded lesbians despite these
shortcomings
this book had real impact at the time it
brought feminism to a very wide audience
and that's a huge positive bill
mckibben's 1989 book the end of nature
is considered to be the first book to
bring global warming to a general
audience
the end of nature is about how humans
are changing the planet it's a sad
lament
on human destruction in the 1980s people
had been talking about global warming
but it hadn't entered the public
consciousness as something
that we should be really concerned about
and we should be
already acting on what he did with this
book
is really wake people up to
this dramatic change that we are having
globally on the natural world and which
now
is taken for granted by everybody we all
are
very aware of the impact we're having
and it's largely due to books like this
things fall apart by nigerian author
chinwa achebe
was one of the first african novels in
english to gain global recognition and
acclaim
and it is still read and studied all
over the world to this day
africa was always seen through the eyes
of the white colonials
it was like a door opening into a world
that white europeans
never understood and even as it
was published people were astonished by
the beauty of the book
here comes a man who's talking about
igbo villages in nigeria
and their lives and their inner thoughts
and their hopes and desires and we'd
never seen that
and for africans and that's the more
important point
there were emerging writers they knew
their time was now they knew that the
world was ready
and it was that book that convinced them
that it was
and finally to post-war britain a time
when many items were still rationed
and to elizabeth david's a book of
mediterranean food
britain already had a reputation for
poor food plain
food gray food she wrote as his
uh memoir almost of her time spent in
southern europe before and during world
war ii
she wrote it really as a yearning for
these wonderful places and the colors
and the scents and the flavors these
days
we completely take for granted
ingredients like
chickpeas lemon garlic olive oil
tomatoes basil then when this book was
published
none of those ingredients were really
available i mean if you wanted to buy
olive oil you had to go to a chemist
shop
because it was sold for treating the era
she triggered a movement which we still
feel today
which is one where food becomes
something important
not just to our daily routine of
nourishing ourselves but saying a little
bit more about who we are
so there's now multiple generations of
food writers and cookery presenters
whose existence now would not have been
possible
without that book words on a page can do
so much more than entertain
some books have imagined explored and
introduced ideas
which have had a lasting impact on our
society which we experience to this day
even if we haven't read them
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video